you treat kids with cancer well
you couldn't have just lied just for the
the mood
you tuned the two two chaps hey now each
other that's your breath your
brother-in-law I was gonna say not
brother because you have the face of
someone who's you know killed people in
a foreign country
and you have the face of someone who
just loves loves life you look
you look like you could advertise candy
with that cherubic smile that is
that's beautiful so
brother-in-law's here what's your
profession brother-in-law
Finance oh [__] [__] yeah everyone here
hates you just a little bit just uh what
type of Finance
Investments yeah we really yeah yeah but
then you're you're you know you're just
sat there do you have a job or has he
got like all the job
a mental health counselor [__] yeah that
balances out the couple
one person is ruining the world and
you're being like no don't kill yourself
well it's just that you know I've got no
money and it's kind of your boyfriend's
fault
um
wow
what what is your favorite mental health
problem to treat
anxiety see there is a good one because
that's
is that because that's the easiest you
like it's probably going to be okay
I I have a lot of friends with anxiety a
lot of the time being anxious I mean
that's the thing isn't it whereas you
know when it's like some of the real
terrible [__] ones you're like yeah
you're [__] me
200 years ago we'd put you in a room and
lock the door and
we kind of don't know how to fix it when
you
[Music]
so you probably didn't want to work in
finance maybe you like I want to be rich
as [__] but what did you want to be
an astronaut
yeah yeah when when you give up on that
dream
you're like it's really hot actually
it's really hard like I think like I
have 80 000 applicants NASA picked like
six people but then you look at Jeff
Bezos he went to space and he's just
Rich so you're doing a pretty good thing
like that's an easier way to get there
that's smart Okay and then again
presumably as a child you're not like oh
I want to help people with mental health
problems because who is that selfless
when they're six years old what did you
want to be a figure skater did you
figure skate up to a certain age and
then pack it in
everything you never even tried
you just you just saw the Nancy Kerrigan
[__] well I'd love to break someone's
knees
that's what I want to do
never even got on the ice just bought a
baseball bat well
so our finance personally wanted to be
an astronaut and our mental health
counselor who wanted to be a figure
skater I mean I don't want to leave out
the the brother-in-law and also partner
yes hello you but you're both so like
you're do you have babies
oh my God they're gonna be so cute
what what do you do
you work in Tech [__] off and then do
you balance it out as well yeah you're a
doctor look at you that's good private
or you know kind of more kind of
socialized Healthcare
this is Americans over there what how
dare you don't bring your propaganda
over here
no I mean like do you go to like kind of
deprived areas and treat people with
like worms in their feet
you're still in training here
specifically here what's your what's
your favorite illness to treat
you treat kids with cancer well yeah
you couldn't have just lied just for the
the mood
okay
wow you just really that's that's I
can't make that funny
um
[__] [__] [__] okay
well don't worry guys you might be like
where's he going with this growing up I
wanted to be a rapper that was my dream
and so uh what I like to do is I like to
find out about people and then uh turn
them into a rap song So DJ do me a favor
drop that beat yeah this this is a
freestyle that is a wrap made up on the
spot based entirely on these people's
lovely lives we've got the man who does
Tech and has a beautiful face you treat
kids with cancer well tread lightly over
your bit of the rap and then the
beautiful couple here uh who you know
one of them's help in the world one of
them is hurting it let's uh let's let's
start with this chirop it faces
beautiful cheeks I see the smile let me
freestyle you be healing all the
Childhood Cancer the answer can it be
funny no it can't the treatment it costs
lots of money if you ain't got it don't
worry your help might be painful the
chemo might make you Yelp you've never
seen anyone rap before about a chat with
leukemia in stage four you wanted to
help them oh plotting you like that be
so strange don't worry soaring he saw
things online like mad respect let me
get wanna be the guy with all the tech
are you a fan of the Zuck a fan of the
bees look at these guys like
millionaires geez when you were a
younger kid you thought you'd report for
school like yo I think Buzz is so cool
that's altering he's holding all of the
cards but then you look upstairs like oh
my God it's more Elon there with the
SpaceX I can't pass through the training
can't face it so I'm gonna work in
finance invest the cash make stuff then
count down and a blast off Cape
Canaveral what am I after I'm the master
spending more money than NASA look at
all the satellites uh earn it on my own
got my AmEx card yes it's not Chrome
it'd be gold solid maybe even platinum C
do you donate money to her surgery yeah
he's nodding even though we know it's a
lie you'd be like I've got the money
apologies you die oh [__] don't worry
you understand Defying Gravity charity
in the hand now my last lady she was so
crazy that's not a good word to use
considering what you do daily helping
other people they're trying to be I
really struggle with my anxiety oh
please sit down I'm gonna bill you right
out of pocket tell me all of your
secrets yeah just drop it I worry that
no one likes me and when I mingle at
parties I'll go home and I'll still be
single well that probably will happen
cause you are a loser that's not how you
do treatment sessions that would be
abusive when you were younger you're
like I'll be nice one day I'll pirouette
and jump on the ice to a triple Salto a
backflip crazy people see me on the ice
there on the daily did you follow
through did you enact this no it's just
a pike ice cream you're like [__] the
Praxis
all right
yeah you guys are lovely thank you very
much my name is
[Applause]